paris et pour démarrer direction berlin
en allemagne où se tient le congrès
mondial des assistants du père noël
bruno albin
ce sont les assistants du père noël
réunis pour leur congrès annuel à
l'université de berlin
c'est pour ainsi dire devenu une
tradition on y chante on essayait ou
plan d' on compare les barbes et surtout
comme dans tous les congrès on écoute
très attentivement le rapport d'activité
présenté par le père noël en personne
cette année nous avons établi un nouveau
record
nous sommes 425 dans cette salle 425
pour la seule ville de berlin
ça fait beaucoup d'assistant mais
d'après ce que cherche le fait depuis
trois ans le chaque année il manque des
pères noël ils font leur chiffre
d'affaires en une seule nuit le 24 près
de 2000 francs en livrant ce à domicile
qualités requises il faut de la
gentillesse du calme et un peu d'humour
il en faut pour savoir rapprocher les
enfants et aux adultes et la cloche
c'est seulement de la réclame la
psychologie est effectivement nécessaire
le prix de la cloche ne marche pas
toujours
mais pour françois qui arrondissait fin
d'année avec le père noël le métier est
vite rentrée et depuis que le mur de
berlin est tombé et lié à 5 ans à berlin
est où l'ancien régime avait affublé le
père noël du surnom de porteur de sac à
dos
le marché est en pleine expansion la
réunification a changé beaucoup de
choses pour le père noël le père noël va
maintenant aussi visiter les familles
dans les quartiers de l'est de la ville
et retour dans les coulisses du congrès
où des contestataires et iconoclaste
contenter de faire courir le bruit qu'il
fallait de cesser de croire au père noël
pourquoi parce qu'il n'existe pas mais a
beaucoup ici
oui mais ils sont tous déguisés
l'insolence n'est pas passée et les
pères noël de berlin ont couvert les
voix discordantes en entonnant le rythme
de toujours mon beau sapin qui est un
peu osons le dire leur international